die schlimmsten befürchtungen sind wahr
geworden wasserretter haben am
dienstagnachmittag bei der absuche des
fulda kanals eine kinderleiche gefunden
es ist die kleine zweijährige tablet die
seit montagabend vermisst wurde
nur wenige meter von dem wohnhaus
entfernt ist ein kanal dort haben
taucher des dlrg die leiche des kleinen
mädchens entdeckt ein rückblick seit
montagabend lief eine großangelegte
suchaktion
die eltern gaben bei der polizei an dass
das mädchen ganz alleine die wohnung
verlassen hat sofort wurden umfangreiche
suchmaßnahmen eingeleitet
mit wärmebildkameras schlauchbooten und
spürhunden suchen die einsatzkräfte
vergeblich stundenlang nach dem kleinen
zweijährigen mädchen in den frühen
morgenstunden wurde die suche dann kurz
unterbrochen dienstagmorgen fortgesetzt
[Musik]
auch am dienstagmorgen kommen wieder
wärmebildkameras und spürhunden zum
einsatz
auch die dlrg ist vor ort am nachmittag
dann die traurige gewissheit das kleine
mädchen ist tot
das ist eine sehr belastende situation
und die polizisten und auch alle anderen
einsatzkräften vor ort sind sehr
betroffen davon
mit reporter julius böhm ist vor ort
er hat diesen tragischen fall beobachtet
julius was kann die polizei im moment
sagen wie konnte dieses zweijährige
mädchen unbemerkt aus dem elternhaus
verschwinden ihren aussagen
hier entdeckt wurde nachgesagt dass es
mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit dieser
zustimmt ist wollte sich aber noch nicht
festlegen weil die weil die
verifizierung noch aussteht weil die
eltern noch informiert worden und man
auch genauer ausschnitt battles
unterbrachte sicher sein ist es ja die
vollzeit gesagt dass das mädchen wohl am
gestrigen abend ganz kurz mit zwei
minuten unbeaufsichtigt war und das
wohnhaus durch eine hintertür verlassen
hat und im anschluss an diesen garten in
dieser hintertür ist der fulda kanal
dort auch der fundort das sind wohl etwa
50 meter vom wohnhaus entfernt wenn du
uns die lage noch etwas beschreiben
könnte es hätte also kann sich das so
vorstellen hier entlang
möglich dass fast alle sehr wichtig
verkehrsadern der stadt
das wohnhaus ist von hier in diese
richtung 250 meter entfernt der kanal
läuft aber parallelstraßen das heißt der
kanal ist eigentlich guter 15 bis 20
meter vom wohnhaus entfernt oder
fundorte kämpft wird bei 250 leser zu
sagen das muss aufhören in diesem hof
ist der hinterhof einer fischfabrik
verläuft der kanal unter erde das heißt
1 stunde läuft unter den gebäuden durch
das wasser steht ungefähr bis 30
zentimeter unterhalb der sekte und
diesen hat die dlrg mit rettungstauchern
durch kemp mit leuchtend und hat da
blieb uns nicht mehr das spiel gefunden
das heißt der kanal ist eigentlich sehr
nah am boden raus und wir sind jetzt
gespannt später weiter aufwärts oder der
schreckliche fund stattfanden
eine arbeit die nicht spurlos an den
rettern vorübergeht vorbeigeht
konntest du kannst mit ihnen sprechen
wie gehen die retter wie gehen die
feuerwehr die polizei die
rettungsdienste die taucher die wasser
taucher dort mit diesem tragischen fall
um werden natürlich mit der polizei
gesprochen das sind alles mütter das
sind alles väter ich habe die frage
gestellt heute mittag ist kalt hat zum
ersten mal geschneit in diesem jahr das
mädchen ist nacht verschwunden der fluss
ist ja in der nähe das gesamte gebiet
hinter diesem hinter diesen fertig
gebäude ist ein auge bieten und mit mit
bayern die vorzeichen denkbar schlecht
aber die polizei hat immer wieder gesagt
nein
unser ziel ist es dieses mädchen zu
finden wir wollen das mädchen schnell
wie es geht ist das familie übermitteln
überbringen es kann kein anderes ziel
geben und das zeigt wie wichtig und
emotional ist den beamten und auf den
kollegen der feuerwehr und auch dass
butt heute es war wirklich gleich die
gedanken zu haben dass dies nur negativ
ausgehen könnte sondern einfach nur zu
sagen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren